let's say that we've got some function f
that is continuous continuous on the
interval A to B so let's try to see if
we can visualize that so this is my
y-axis that's my y-axis this right over
here I'm going to make it my t axis well
we'll use X a little bit later so I'll
call this my T axis and then let's say
that this right over here is the graph
of y is equal to f of T y is equal to f
of T and we're saying it's continuous on
the interval from A to B so this is T is
equal to a this is T is equal to B so
we're saying that it is continuous it is
continuous over this whole interval now
for fun let's define a function capital
f of X and I will do it in blue let's
define capital f of X as equal to the
definite integral from a from a as a
lower bound to X to X of F of T let me
do that of F of T of F of T DT where X
is in this interval where where a is
less than or equal to X is less than or
equal to B or that's just another way of
saying that X is in this interval right
over here now when you see this you
might say oh you know the definite
integral this has to do with
differentiation and anti derivatives and
all that but we don't know that yet all
we know right now is that this is the
area under the curve F between a and X
so between a and let's say this right
over here this right over here is X so f
of X is just is just this area this area
right over here that's all we know about
it we don't know it has anything to do
with anti derivatives just yet that's
what we're going to try to prove in this
video so just for fun let's take the
derivative of F and we're going to do it
just using the definition of derivatives
and see what that what we get when we
take the derivative using the definition
derivatives so we would get so the
derivative F prime of X well this
definition of derivatives it's the limit
as Delta X approaches zero of capital f
of X plus Delta X minus f of X all of
that all of that over Delta X this is
just the definition of the derivative
now what is this equal to well let me
rewrite it using these integrals right
up here this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to the limit
the limit as Delta X approaches zero of
what's f of X plus Delta X well put X in
right over here you're going to get the
definite integral from a to X plus Delta
X of F of T DT and then from that you
are going to subtract you are going to
subtract this business f of X which
we've already written as the integral
from a the definite integral from a to X
of F of T DT and then all of that is
over Delta X all of this is over all of
this is over Delta X now what is this
represent remember we don't know
anything about definite integrals to
somehow dealing with something with an
antiderivative and all that we just know
this this is another way of saying the
area under the curve F between a and X
plus Delta X so it's the area under the
curve F between a and X plus Delta X X
plus Delta X so it's this entire area
it's this entire area right over here so
that's this part we already know what
this blue stuff is this blue stuff in
that same shade of blue so this blue
stuff right over here
this is equal to all of this business
we've already shaded this in it's equal
to all of this business right over here
so if you were to take all of this green
area which is from a to X plus Delta X
and subtract out this blue area which is
exact
what we're doing in the numerator what
are you left with well you're going to
be left with you're going to be left
with what color have I not used yet
maybe I will use this pink color well
now I already use that I'll use this
purple color you're going to be left
with this area you're going to be left
with this area right over here so what's
another way of writing that well another
way of writing this area right over here
is the definite integral between X and X
plus Delta X of F of T of F of T DT so
we can rewrite this entire expression
the derivative of capital f of X this is
capital F prime of X we can rewrite it
now as being equal to the limit as Delta
X approaches 0 this I can write as 1
over Delta X times the numerator the
numerator we already figured out the
numerator the green area minus the blue
area is just the purple area which is
and another way of sewing is denoting
that area is this expression right over
here so 1 over Delta X times the
definite integral from X to X plus Delta
X of F of T F of T DT now this
expression is interesting this might
look familiar from the mean value
theorem of definite integrals the mean
value theorem of definite integrals
tells us so the mean mean value theorem
of definite definite integrals definite
integrals tells us there exists there
exists a C in in the interval so I could
see where I'll write this way where a is
less than or equal to C which is less
than or actually let me make it clear
the interval that we now care about is
between X and X plus Delta X where at
where X is less than or equal to C which
is less than or equal to X plus Delta X
such that such that the function
evaluated at C the function of value C
so let me draw this
see so there's a see someplace over here
so if I were to take the function
evaluated at the C so that's F of C
right over here so if I were to take the
function evaluate the C which would
essentially be the height of this line
and I multiply it times the base this
interval if I multiply it times the
interval which and this interval is just
Delta X X plus Delta X minus X is just
Delta X so if we just multiply the
height times the base times the base
that this is going to be equal to the
area under the curve is going to be
equal to the area under the curve which
is the definite integral from X to X
plus Delta X X to X plus Delta X of F of
T f of T DT this is what the mean value
theorem of integrals tells us if f is a
continuous function there exists two C
in this interval between our two
endpoints between our two end points
where the function evaluated the C is
essentially you can view it as the mean
height and if you take that mean value
of the function and you multiply it
times the base you're going to get the
area of the curve or another way of
rewriting this you could say that F of C
there exists a C in that interval where
f of C is equal to 1 over Delta X I'm
just dividing both sides by Delta X
times the definite integral from X to X
plus Delta X of F of T DT and this is
often viewed as the mean value of the
function over the interval why is that
well this part right over here this part
right over here gives you the area and
then you divide the area by the base and
you get the mean height or another way
you could say it is if you were to take
the height right over here multiply it
times the base you get a rectangle that
has the exact same area as the area
under the curve well this is useful
because this is exactly what we got as
the derivative of F prime of X so there
must exist a C such that such that F of
C is equal to this stuff or we could say
that the limit and let me rewrite all of
this down a new color so there exists
there exists a C in the interval X to X
plus Delta X where
we're F prime of X which we know is
equal to this if we can now say is now
equal to the limit as Delta X approaches
zero instead of writing this we know
that there's some C that's equal to all
of this business of f of C now we're in
the homestretch we just have to figure
out what the limit as Delta X approaches
0 of f of C is and the main realization
is this part right over here we know
that C is always sandwiched in between X
and X plus Delta X and intuitively you
could tell that look as Delta X
approaches 0 is Delta X as this Green
Line as this green line right over here
moves more and more to the left as it
approaches this as it approaches this
blue line as it approaches this blue
line the C has to be in between and so
the C is going to approach X so we know
intuitively we know intuitively that C
approaches X as Delta X Delta X
approaches 0 or another way of saying it
is that F of C is going to approach f of
X as Delta X as Delta X approaches 0 and
so intuitively we could say that this is
going to be equal to F of this is going
to be equal to f of X now you might say
ok that's intuitively but we're kind of
working on a little bit of a proof here
Sal tell them let me know for sure that
X is going to approach you don't just do
this little thing where you drew this
diagram and it makes sense that C is
going to have to get closer and closer
to X and if you want that you could just
resort to the squeeze theorem and to
resort to the squeeze theorem you just
have to view C as a function of Delta X
and it really is depending on your Delta
X C is going to be further to the left
or to the right possibly and so I can
just rewrite this expression as X is
less than or equal to C as a function of
Delta X which is less than or equal to X
plus Delta X so now you see that C is
always sandwiched between X and X plus
Delta X well what's the limit of X as
Delta X approaches 0 well X is
independent on Delta X in any way so
this is just going to be equal to X
what's the limit of X plus
Delta X as Delta X approaches zero well
as Delta X approaches 0 this is just
going to be equal to X so if this
approaches X is X Delta X approaches
zero and it's less than this function
and if this approaches X is Delta X
approaches zero and it's always greater
than this then we know from the squeeze
theorem or the sandwich theorem that the
limit as Delta X approaches 0 of C as a
function of Delta X is going to be equal
to is going to be equal to X as well it
has to approach the same thing that that
and that is it's sandwiched in between
and so that's a slight we resort to the
sandwich theorem it's a little bit more
rigorous to get to this exact result as
Delta X approaches 0 C approaches X if C
is approaching X then F of C is going to
approach f of X and then we essentially
have our proof F is a continuous
function we defined f in this way
capital f in this way and we were able
to use just the definition of the
derivative to figure out that the
derivative of capital f of X is equal to
is equal to is equal to f of X and once
again why is this a big deal well it
tells you that if you have any
continuous function f and that's what we
assume we assume that f is continuous
over the interval there exists some
function there exist a function you can
just define the function this way is the
area under the curve between between
some endpoint or the the beginning of
the interval and some X if you define a
function in that way the derivative of
this function is going to be equal to
your continuous function or another way
of saying it is that you always have an
antiderivative that any continuous
function has an antiderivative and so
it's a couple of cool things any
continuous function has an
antiderivative is going to be that
capital it's going to be that capital f
of X and this is why it's called the
fundamental theorem of calculus it ties
together these two ideas and you have
differential calculus you have the ideas
you have the idea of a derivative
and then an integral calculus you have
the idea of an integral before this
proof all we viewed an integral as is
the area under the curve is it was just
literally a notation to say the area
under the curve but now we've been able
to make a connection that there's a
connection between the integral and the
derivative or connection between the
integral and the antiderivative in
particular so it connects all of
calculus together in a very very very
powerful and and we were so used to it
now and and and now we can say almost a
somewhat obvious way but it wasn't
obvious remember we always think of
integrals as somehow doing an
antiderivative but it wasn't clear if
you just viewed an integral as only an
area you would have to go through this
process a Wow no it's connected it's
connected to the process of taking a
derivative